payet une autre question que je les
soulever ce soir d'ailleurs sur ce sujet
c'est celle qui a été soulevée d'abord
par les employés du louvre et maintenant
par les chauffeurs de bus qui invoque un
droit qui s'appelle le droit de retrait
notamment ce syndicaliste cfdt
il a fallu lundi commençait les droits
de retrait dès 4 heures du matin pour
qu'à 15 heures on nous ramène un carton
de gel et qu'on nous dise voilà
maintenant on va donner du gel mais que
à ceux qui vont conduire et sous des
charges de signature donc soit vous
signez vous roulez on vous donne sans
vous donne rien puis à 19h au
retournement de situation nous avions en
fin de compte on vous donne rien du tout
donc aujourd'hui rebelote on a tous
appliquer notre droit de retrait alors
est ce légitime ce droit de retrait
selon vous le rende retraite il légitime
à cause du coronavirus c'est la question
que vous pose sur twitter voici la
réponse de la ministre des transports
elisabeth bornes j'ai aussi dit aux
entreprises et aux branches
professionnelles que j'avais en face de
moi qu'il est très important qui est
bien du dialogue social au sein des
entreprises
informé des recommandations des
autorités sanitaires
des précautions qui sont prises dans les
entreprises quand toutes ces précautions
sont prises
y a pas lieu d'exercer un droit de
retrait les salariés doivent être
rassurés alors sylvie morel dans une
autre vie vous avez été d âge quel est
votre point de vue justement sur ce
recours au droit de retrait dans une
autre vie quand j'ai été drh m'enfin
c'est vraiment vrai notre vie notre est
pas que le droit de retrait qui existait
était quand même manipulé très
sérieusement par les syndicats bon je
rappelle juste pour le lancement du
point de vue juridique
droit de retrait danger grave et
imminent bon alors c'est le juge qui
apprécieront à supposer qu'ils le
veuillent bon juste propos je regarde un
peu la jurisprudence
c'est difficile parce qu'évidemment il
n'y a pas de situation vraiment
comparable on peut juste dire que je
croise en 2012 la ratp les conducteurs
de bus et c'était avec zèle c'est un
droit de retrait pour danger mais s'il
ya un problème de sécurité mais tous les
conducteurs de bus d'une ville alors que
le quartier concerné stade seul quartier
qui était dangereux
les juges avaient considéré qu'il ait
pas de l'exercice du droit de retrait
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire encore
que je pense que si ici de ce droit de
retrait est justifié alors que le droit
de retrait est justifié pour pour
énormément de travailleurs la jeune
femme là qui vient de nous maquiller
tous autant que nous sommes dans cette
table était beaucoup plus près de nos
visages que les gardiens du louvre ou
que les rats tp je pense pas que les
gardiens du louvre on exige qu'ils
embrassent les visiteurs chinois
je plaisante un petit peu mais bon sa ds
je pense qu'ils autre chose dire on l'a
vu tout à l'heure à nouveau des dans les
rapports sociaux de ces entreprises je
suppose alors en tout cas les personnes
les internautes qui sont exprimés qui
votent sur twitter eux estiment que les
c'est légitime le droit de retrait
légitime à cause du cornât virus c'est
la question qu'on vous pose la sur
twitter et vous est pour l'instant une
majorité une petite majorité à répondre
oui à 53%
alexis d'abord l'aspect juridique qui
aurait compliqué parce que c'est dans la
loi danger grave et imminent mais est on
invoque ya pas en apporter la preuve
et c'est après le ou les tribunaux
disent oui vous aviez le droit vous
n'aviez pas le droit donc dé facto c'est
une question de rapport de forces se
rapporte au fonds social
je pense effectivement que souvent c'est
le faux nez d'autres choses c'est à dire
que quand une situation de conflit quand
il ya des inquiétudes qui ça vient se
greffer on va invoquer un droit de
retrait est ce que aujourd'hui il ya un
danger grave et imminent tout à l'heure
où tout le monde se sent en danger
le problème d'une épidémie c'est que
c'est un danger pour tout le monde
est-ce qu'il est grave ça dépend
si on regarde les statistiques on peut
dire non mais on peut dire si je suis de
1% qui a la forme grave de la maladie
oui et est-ce qu'il est imminent il est
potentiel donc le truc en face ce qu'on
se dit mais c'est du bon sens et que si
les chauffeurs commence invoqué ça ne
payait plus de vue on va pas arrêter non
plus le pays pendant des mois et des
mois sous prétexte qu'il ya une épidémie
donc moi ça me paraît excessif alors
qu'après il utilise à peut-être pour
avoir des des précautions et que des
employés demandent à leur employeur
rassemble de précaution si c'est un
moyen d'obtenir quelque chose oui c'est
un moyen d'arrêter de travailler où
va-t-on paraît quand même compliqué tous
les tous les métiers sont impactés
doivent prendre les précautions nous dit
arcus 10 et dans un bus il ya moins de
5000 personnes sensées allusion à la
mesure qui a été pris dans le cadre du
stade 2 du plan orson et qui d'ailleurs
expliqué sur figure live dans un sujet
comment la france se prépare à une
épidémie
laurence taillade juste juste avant pour
dire que cette mesure de 5000 n'a aucun
n'a pas de sens médical c'est un sens
administratif parce que c'est le seul
rassemblement qu'ils ont soumis à
autorisation donc un peu les interdire
voilà donc on dit c'est 5000 mais c'est
pas moins dangereux à 5100 que enfin
plus dangereux samedi 5 à 4900 ou que
même à deux millions c'est simplement
qu'on peut interdire juridiquement des
rassemblements de plus de cinq mille
parce qu'il faut une autorisation pour
les avants les avants 5000 on n'est pas
obligé d'honorer déclaré bien sûr le
droit de retrait est un droit que chaque
salarié peut exercer à condition de
justifier par un risque individuel et
identifiable fils dudit philippe qui
nous regardent c'est votre point de vue
également mon point de vue c'est
qu'effectivement il peut y avoir des
abus c'était le cas aussi à la sncf ya
quelques mois ou un droit de retrait
ressemble et aussi plus ou moins une
grève parce que la zone qui étaient
concernés par des problématiques s'est
retrouvé beaucoup plus étendue en termes
d'arrêts de travail
maintenant la question qui se pose je
pense c'est surtout la question du doute
du 12 par rapport à l'autorité en règle
générale c'est le doute de l'autorité
médicale le doute face face au
gouvernement et ce doute il est
entretenu par l'incohérence dans
laquelle on se trouve aujourd'hui on
voit bien que le gouvernement gère la
situation de façon totalement
incohérente
on a parlé cette histoire
d'interdictions administratives pour les
rassemblements de plus de cinq mille
personnes
on a parlé la semaine dernière de cette
histoire de
match de foot il ya eu il ya eu un
scandale aussi en ce week end où on a
fermé des marchés alors qu'il y avait au
bout des supermarchés ou au bout d des
parkings des supermarchés
donc on voit bien que cette incohérence
est en train d'entretenir le doute et le
doute fait que des salariés peut-être se
sentent en danger
donc évidemment il doit y avoir ce
discours et ce dialogue avec les patrons
parce que je trouve que c'est normal que
des salariés demandent du gel
hydroalcoolique parce qu'ils sont dans
l'inquiétude
il faut laisser il faut les rassurer il
faut les équiper correctement
et si le droit de retrait est exercée
dans ce sens là je pense qu'il est
totalement légitime
alors si vous n'avez pas de gel
hydroalcoolique l'a encore demandé sur
figaro live puisque on vous expliquera
comment on fabrique est en tout cas les
recettes qui sont pris dans une trop
forte et très grande des droits connexes
est très symbolique et d'en trouver
il ya des ruptures de stock ou la
rupture de stock également pour les
masquer la production des masques et
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron annoncé leur
réquisition tout à l'heure je rappelle
que d'ailleurs le dernier bilan en
france fait état de deux cent quatre cas
confirmés 13 de plus qu'hier et
désormais quatre morts et je reviens sur
le gel hydroalcoolique donc pouvoir
retrouver les recettes de 20 le conseil
de l' oms pour en faire et cette vidéo
sur fear alive renault si on vous envoie
sur une zone où il ya du corona virus
vous exercer votre droit de retrait
alors si le dialecte l'action qui est
mon patron qui est là me demande d'aller
à one j'y vais demain parce que ça fait
un très intéressant et que je considère
qu'il ne me demandez ne me pèse il ne me
mets pas face à danger inconsidérés
parce que il faut voir ce que c'est que
cette épidémie
c'est pas la peste noire c'est pas la
même pas la grippe espagnole
c'est une crypte on a beaucoup de grip
en france tous des angles et c'est une
grippe et des morts en france
c'était une vieille dame de 89 ans 1 89
ans elle en arrive on meurt il faut bien
mourir de quelque chose voilà voilà
mais
60 ans qui est mort c'est l'enseignant
un enseignant de l'oise qui revenait
d'italie davet mai
oui je pense que je pense qu'en tout cas
le drop un journaliste sur un phénomène
aussi important est évidemment de
couvrir la situation parce que sinon
vous n'êtes plus journal il faut faire
un autre métier
je vous pose des questions je pose la
question différemment chardon qui nous
regardent nous dit à force de minimiser
à présent la psychose est là est-ce que
cela vous n'êtes pas en train de
justement de minimiser et de minimis la
cccd grippe oui à des grilles pour on va
on va trouver bientôt un vaccin va
espérons le c'est pas la première grippe
qu'on a eu c'est pas la dernière
c'est pas non plus la peste noire si
vous voulez ce que je veux dire c'est
par exemple n'y a pas un seul enfant est
mort il ya beaucoup il ya eu beaucoup de
morts gilles 3000 il n'y a pas un seul
enfant qu'est mort de cette grippe
pas sympa voilà d'accord donc des jeunes
organismes résiste quand même bien assez
vite alors qu'on prenne toutes les
mesures pour la combattre ou y mais j'ai
mais je pense que dans une société
organisée il faut il faut avoir
confiance dans le gouvernement et dans
les autorités sanitaires c'est tout à
fait et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui se passe
en chine
et puis je pense qu'il ya une
dégradation cours des dernières années
du service public
en fait les individus s'arrogent le
droit de savoir si il faut il faut
accomplir une obligation de service
public ou pas je pense que c'est pas à
eux de le faire on est je suis favorable
des sociétés organisées et c'est pas aux
individus à décider si oui ou non il
il faut conduire leur bus il est évident
que la ratp fera tout pour éviter que ne
se propage pas
le virus dont le corps n'a virus est
évident est ce que dans l'histoire pour
revenir à l'histoire des 5000 de
rassemblement de 5000 personnes donc on
est dans le nez dans le procès dure on
est ce qu'on n'est pas un petit peu
quand même c'est la limite de ceux des
réactions face à ce phénomène où on
applique des procédures c'est un stade
de stade iii et finalement gabriel attal
disait on essaie d'avoir une réponse
adaptée mais la réponse n'est pas
adaptée on répond plus par départ des
procédures civiles
je sais pas si elle n'est pas adaptée
bon moi plus généralement que ça ce qui
m'agace c'est là on a un fléau bon il
n'est pas chez accor êtes-vous je pense
pas que ce soit hyper grave et moi aussi
gérer agréable même si je fais pas
partie de la rédaction du figaro je vous
accompagnerai volontiers mais vous
pourrez parler aussi de responsabilités
c'est vrai c'est vrai de grâce aux gens
qui n'ont pas forcément envie de courir
les mêmes risques un jour n'absolument
en mai mais c'est vrai qu'au delà de ça
oui là on a un phénomène un fléau encore
une fois la ratp gare de louvres et à un
moment donné
mobilisons nous soyons un peu courageux
moi j'ai peur ces gardiens du nous
supposons qu'il ya un incendie quand je
visite le louvre il doit être formé
quand même hammam évacués de serra
franchement je trouve que tout ça manque
vraiment de courage je parle pas pour
eux je ferais pareil pour moi je trouve
qu'elle a une espèce de fuite on
n'arrête pas de râler manque du gel oui
il manque du gel c'est normal on n'a pas
produit on a pas des tonnes de tonnes de
gel dans les pharmacies on n'est pas
prévu il va arriver
il ya un côté râleur la kim qui m'agace
extrêmement bon cela dit dans un pays
je termine là dessus pour une boutade
mais je sais que vous en avez parlé hier
mais où florence foresti exerçait les
mêmes son droit de retrait du nez mais
surtout été possible c'est un autre
débat et on l'a pas abordé ce soir c'est
un débat de point de vue c'est un débat
des points de vue sans aborder la
question des césar au sida ont fait
comme toujours
oui alors
il ya ce problème de gel hydro
alcoolique ou les gens pensent qu'on ne
peut se laver les mains qu'avec du gel
hydro alcoolique il faut rappeler qu on
peut se servir aussi de savon et que
c'est très efficace et ce que font les
chirurgiens avant une opération donc on
peut faire confiance au savon et en
l'occurrence quand on est employé du
louvre on n'a pas besoin de gel
hydroalcoolique parce que théoriquement
on à du savon et on a tout ce qu'il faut
dans les toilettes pour se laver les
mains
ça c'est la première chose par contre
concernant les transports en commun oui
moi j'ai une réelle inquiétude et je les
prends régulièrement je prends le métro
quand on se retrouvent entassés dans un
métro on entend les gens dire ah bah là
s'il en est un qui a le coronavirus on
l'a tous parce que c'est la vérité
on est dans une telle situation de
promiscuité moi ça m'amuse d'entendre ah
bah oui il faut se mettre dos à dos mais
on décide pas de comment semer dans le
métro quand il est blindé vous prenez la
ligne 13 à 18h vous décidez pas déjà
vous essayer de monter dans le métro
donc là il ya effectivement cette vraie
question qui est pas la question des
conducteurs mais la question des
personnes qui sont transportés et la
responsabilité individuelle des
personnes qui rentrent des zones à
risques qui auraient été en contact avec
des malades qui ont par contre ont
parfois des comportements irresponsables
et c'est la région est la raison de la
propagation de la maladie
la vérité c'est qu'on est en fait nous
les autorités très désarmés et on a plus
l'habitude de ça on avait dansé t on à
l'impression que tout est sous contrôle
et les épidémies ça nous renvoie à une
baisse de 2 de pulsions première
d'angoise d'inquiétude de choses qui
nous tombe du ciel est ce que c est
parce qu on sait pas le virus qui
flottent et le fou c'est qu'on sait pas
et quand et vous disiez qu'il ya une fin
juste manqué une méfiance vis-à-vis des
autorités parce qu'elles donnent le
sentiment 2 mai donne pas le sentiment
elles savent pas mais personne ne sait
le et donc on est face à une situation
qui n'est pas pas connus par maîtriser
pas maîtrisable dont on peut se dire
rationnellement qu'elle n'est pas si
grave
oui mais l'inconnu l'incertitude donc la
défiance donc ça c'est inévitable et
s'est même rationnelle c'est à dire que
comment ne pas éprouver de la défiance
face à une situation incertaine et non
maîtrisée
oui donc c'est ces factures d'eau et la
raison c'est de dire mais n'ayez pas
peur mais au fond on n'en sait rien
donc oui s'est insurgé coordonnées
rational de chaussée la société où les
gens attendent tout de l'état et
aujourd'hui se rendent compte que
finalement l'état ne peut pas dans cette
situation à l'idée que ce danger est
inconnu saj de tournai un sociologue le
dire je crois que c'était enfin bref je
trouve ça pertinents face à un danger
inconnue c'est exactement ce que dit on
essaie désormais alors que peut-être
parmi ces conducteurs de la ratp il ya
sans doute des fumeurs et là il ya un
danger connu clair bon mais ça c'est un
danger qu'on est loin de quel on habite
fait selon vous le droit de retrait est
il légitime à cause du coronavirus donc
c'est la question que vous posez sur
tweets et vous a répondu oui à 53% show
signal l'autre question c'est de savoir
si elle est posée sur le site du figaro
on y reviendra peut-être dans les
prochains jours l'épidémie de
coronavirus peut-elle vous dissuader
d'aller voter aux municipales est là
pour l'instant
vous avez encore envie d'aller voter en
tout cas une forte participation à
prévoir chez les internautes qui se sont
exprimés sur le site du figaro est bon
on va parler précisément de politique
promis juré la droite n'a rien à voir
avec la gauche radicale promis juré il y
aura bien deux motions de censure
déposée il ya bien deux motions de
censure déposées pour dénoncer le
recours gouvernementales aux 49 3
premier juré l'opposition des
républicains n'a rien à voir avec celle
des insoumis à droite on se pose parce
qu'on veut la retraite à 65 ans la fin
des régimes spéciaux à gauche est
exactement l'inversé
ça c'est ce que rappelle damien abad le
président du groupe verts à l'assemblée
mais ça n'a pas convaincu la majorité en
marche qui dément